we are now in position to find the
accelerations a1 a2 in the tension
because we have Newton's second law and
our constraint condition for the
acceleration let's recall the equations
that we found we had M 1 G minus T was
m1 a1 and we had m2 G minus 2 T was
equal to m2 a2 and we also had the
condition constraint condition between
the accelerations that a1 was minus 2 a
2 so now we have a system of three
equations and we can find we can solve
for any of these quantities that we want
so one way to do it is to identify an
equation and to identify the quantity
that we would like to solve for so for
instance let's identify that we want to
solve for a 1 first
so how are we going to develop a
strategy for that well I'll choose
equation 1 as my backbone equation and I
have an unknown T but in equation 2 that
unknown T is appearing there but it's
expressed in terms of a 2 and a 2 though
from Equation 3 is expressed in terms of
a 1 so my first step is to write
equation rewrite equation 2 as m2 G
minus 2 T equals m2 now here is I'm
going to make the substitution which is
minus a 1 over 2 so we'll call that 2a
and now I have equation 1 and equation 2
a 2 unknowns T and a 1 and what I can do
is I can solve for either equation and I
can make a choice what's easiest when I
look at these equations it's easiest for
me to identify what T is in terms of a 1
so I'll write M 1 G minus M 1 a 1 is
equal to T I'll call that equation 1 a
and now I can substitute that value of T
into equation 2 a and I get m2 G minus 2
times M 1 G minus M 1
and that's equal to minus em 2 over 2
times a 1 and now I'd like to collect my
a 1 terms and what I have over here
let's bring all the a 1 terms to this
side and I get em 2 gee minus 2 & 1 gee
I have a plus so I'm going to bring that
over to this side and I get equal to
that's plus plus so I'll have 2 minus
signs and I'll have to M 1 plus M 2 over
2 a 1 and now I can solve for a 1 and
what I get is I get 2 & 1 G minus m2g
and I want to divide through by this
denominator and what I have downstairs
is 2 m 1 plus M 2 divided by 2 and
that's my expression for a 1 once I have
that expression for a 1 I can easily
come back and find out what a 2 is or I
can substitute into the equation here
for a 1 and find out what the tension is
and so I can now easily find my
expressions for a 2 and T but I will
leave that as an exercise